and the actor goes to Brad Pitt for once
a week and the actor it goes to Jennifer
Aniston the most memorable moments from
the 2020 SAG Awards and yeah a big part
of the night was about Brad Pitt and
Jennifer Aniston's reunion what do you
make of all the ridiculousness about you
and Brad reuniting on all these carpets
all season long it's hysterical but what
else are they gonna talk about that was
Jen on the carpet right before both she
and Brad won in their categories I'm
gonna add this to my tinder profile Brad
made a dating profile joke before joking
about the parallels between his life and
his role and once upon a time in
Hollywood let's be honest it was a
difficult part a guy who gets high takes
his shirt off and doesn't get on with
his wife it's a big stretch Jen watch
Brad supportively and when she won she
got emotional oh my gosh I mean who knew
that emotional breakdowns felt that good
it was literally like you know seven
months of therapy covered about 20 years
of work so thank you for watching that
but the moment that really had fans
talking was when Brad took a second to
watch her speech from backstage I think
I knew I forgot to thank my freaking
cast we'll do it here come on this
extraordinary cast every single one of
them was a lovely welcome back it's been
a long time and that's what I meant when
I said you know I know when this we want
to come and get invited into this room
it's really special because it's my it's
my peers and we're still not over these
backstage pics but there were other big
moments from the awards show to Eugene
and Dan levees father-son opening had
everyone laughing for this incredibly
glamorous group of people tonight sag is
such an unfortunate acronym Alex
Borstein was also hilarious after the
cast of mrs. Basel beat out fleabag in
the Best Comedy category I voted for
fleabag this is really weird this
no sense I don't know what to say I'm
gonna take this home and make sweet love
to it through my Spanx hole anyone else
got anything to say we won last year so
I guess I just figured it was fleabags
here cuz I mean you know it's it's every
show that was nominated this is
fantastic but I feel like she was like
from an actor's standpoint I look at
Phoebe baller bridge and she wrote it
she created it it started from this
one-person show it's just such this
incredible success story other sweet
moments include Michelle Williams giving
a sweet but rare shout-out to daughter
Matilda Matilda it's one thing to be
completely honest as an actor it's
another thing to be completely honest as
a human being and that's just who you
are and how you live and you teach me
just by being you know I love you and
I'm coming home when Joaquin Phoenix won
he turned the spotlight on the other men
nominated in his Best Actor category
you've been an inspiration for over 25
years to me and so many people I thank
you very very much you commit to your
roles in ways that I can only dream of
you never turn into bad performance it's
infuriating I wish you would one time
just suck once okay okay he also paid
tribute to Heath Ledger who played the
Joker before he did really I'm standing
here on the shoulders of my favorite
actor Heath Ledger so thank you and good
night other big winners included Renee
Zellweger Peter Dinklage and the team
behind parasites but of course it
wouldn't be an award show without some
political talk and Robert De Niro did
just that when he accepted his Lifetime
Achievement Award as a citizen I have as
much right as anybody an actor an
athlete a musician anybody to voice my
opinion and if I have a bigger voice
because of my situation I'm going to use
it whenever I see a blatant
abuse of power